صحيح هنا هذه المشكله انه طالبان هم هذا
مبرر وانا تحدثت عده مرات حتى هم عندما
يبررون هذه الاسباب هم لا يقتنعوا بانفسهم
فقط محاوله لرسم صوره امام شعبه الافغاني
بانه هناك همم المناعه زاد المناهج
الغربيه فرضها الغرب فرضها الاحتلال
الافغانستان ولكن في الحقيقه المناهج
موحده سواء في المدارس او الجامعات بين
همم الطلبه والطالبات باذن الله لا يوجد
اي فرق اللهم ممكن قد يحدث فرق بعض المواد
في كل الدول العالم والمدارس التي كانت
منفصله بين البنين والبنات هناك مواد تدرس
همم
تناسب طبيعه الفتاه يعني صحيح هذا هو لكن
جميع المناهج نتحدث عن المواد الموحده
جميع موحده فهذه الزواجات الطالبان طالبان
يعني تريد ان تفرض باي طريقه لا تريد ان
المراه تعمل
او تتعلم حتى يعني فهذه بالنسبه هي افكار
متطرفه